most of us live completely unfree
completely outsourced completely
automated lives and everyone is spending
all of their energy responding to the
Past running out and trying to
anticipate the future and we don't have
the skills to be present where we
are mindfulness is simply the gap
between stimulus and response between my
body feels this thing and what do I do
next how do you lengthen that Gap so
choosing mindfulness as a part of
building a non-anxious life is
cultivating two important ways of doing
life being aware and being
[Music]
curious think of awareness as ownership
of your life at
360° Can You Feel the good stuff and the
bad stuff can you feel this might happen
and can you also feel but it probably
won't
awareness is looking around your life
and taking inventory and ownership of it
when somebody cuts you off in traffic
and your body instantly responds with a
story that you've made up about the
driver of that car that's not being
aware that's being automated and dumping
it on that guy in that car because you
can also choose another story you can
sharply intake your breath until you
know you're safe and you can
exhale you get to decide the narrative
and you get to ask yourself this
question why is my body responding like
that what is my body trying to protect
me from when you get a email at 4:00 on
a Friday from your boss that says I need
to see you immediately why does your
body instantly go to war why does your
body instantly want to Sprint to the
parking lot and drive away is it because
you have an untrustworthy boss is it
because you you know you're about to get
fired or is it because since you were a
little kid anytime an adult called you
on the carpet you knew you were going to
get scolded and Sham and hit and this
boss is just another adult in a long
line of people who treated you less then
awareness is about looking at your
entire life taking ownership of how you
feel and that leads me to
curiosity curiosity is the choice to not
instantly judge throw rocks at take
swings at people at actions at ideas
curiosity is sitting back at
asking why did she say that I wonder why
that politician keeps doing that I
wonder why the teacher at my kid School
said that instead of instantly jumping
to fight or flight or freeze instead of
instantly jumping towards I have to
react I have to go do being aware of how
your body is responding to certain
things and being curious about why
that's
happening gives you a moment to breathe
and it gives you a moment to decide what
happen
next so when you first start being
Mindful and you first start being aware
of things and being curious about things
you're going to be overwhelmed with
feelings and it's important to
understand feelings are not designed to
tell you the truth feelings are designed
to keep you safe feelings are designed
to keep you connected even if that
connection's
unsafe feelings are not designed to tell
you the truth they are data but they're
corrupted data they're important but
they don't tell the truth and so an
important part of being curious being
aware is asking the question is that
true is that for real is your husband
really the worst person ever is your
boss really the worst person ever most
people are just like you doing the best
they can to get through the day and they
want friends and they want laughter and
they want connection and they want huh
never thought of it that way or they
want that's stupid that's mindfulness
that's
awareness somebody would call into my
show they call in and say hey John I've
heard you screaming and yelling at your
kids especially when they're little
hurts them it's not good but my
5-year-old keeps banging everything and
my 3-year-old keeps pulling everything
off the counters and every time I clean
up this mess they're over here making up
a new mess and my newborn won't stop
screaming and so finally when my
5-year-old comes down and says can I
have a snack can I have a snack can I
have a snack I snap and I yell and
scream how do I not do
that this is where mindfulness comes
into play this is where awareness and
curiosity save the
day because let's back up for one second
right before you yell let's be aware
this is your feelings not theirs this is
your rage and anger and frustration and
it shouldn't be this way not theirs and
awareness gives us one tiny little
millisecond before we respond and in
that millisecond we can remember they're
five of course they bang on things
they're three of course they don't have
motor control and they just want to see
what happens when they pull a thing off
the wall and that leads us to curiosity
why am I so enraged
oh cuz I thought motherhood would feel
different I thought my kids would behave
if I was a good mom I didn't realize
kids sometimes misbehave just because
they're kids it was my expectations and
it was my bricks in my backpack that I
brought to this scenario not theirs and
then you can smile and you can go this
isn't the season for a clean house this
isn't the season for Perfection this
isn't the season for doing everything
perfectly this is the season when I have
a infant and a 3-year-old and a
5-year-old and you can make
peace
so I left work the other day and I was
raged out I was super angry and in the
car I was driving home and I started
laughing and I was like how is this
solving this right like there was there
was nothing I could do about what I was
mad about in my car on my way to my
house being
angry driving too fast grabbing the
wheel that tight solved none of my
issues and so then I texted my wife and
said something don't like to say I had a
hard one today I'm coming in kind of hot
and she said I'll have dinner and a hug
and a show ready cuz those are things
that aren't going to solve my problem at
work but it is going to make me more
whole right whenever I get spun up on
something what can I control about this
thing mindfulness it's about being aware
it's about being curious is this
actually working for me is this actually
providing me relief from the thing I'm
so upset or frustrated about mindfulness
will save you it'll save us
all